do you play with clitorises yeah I will  play with clitoris you will play did you  watch the orgasm documentary they had a  whole like group where the most  sensitive part of the clitoris is like  upper that's a clitoris nail I deal with  giant clitted women yeah so this is the  clitoris yeah like it was called one  touch and they would just rub that part  and they said the pressure should be  like turning the page on a book which  you've probably never done yeah I don't  know I don't know Turn the page on a  book for 15 minutes straight you have to  rub it for 15. and you believe that they  need to there was a whole group and it  was like effective and would you do that  I've never done it but it's good  information to have yeah  I downloaded the software update but  look you guys this guy's [ __ ] his way  to robot heaven I don't know what that  means  I was in it